I still remember the first time I
traveled to Southern California it was
the summer of 1984 and Los Angeles was
hosting the Olympics Reagan was
president and Republican George
Deukmejian was the state's governor now
he was a moderate conservative a
law-and-order kind of guy the whole
place to me at least felt like a Beach
Boys song it was a weather that people
the lifestyle it was all you know
beautiful stuff but today the sunshine
notwithstanding California is a very
different place it's now a place where
state officials actively thwart federal
authorities trying to stop violent
criminal offenders Oakland's mayor Libby
Schaaf went so far as to issue a warning
to immigrant communities that an ice
raid was forthcoming well the president
sounded off on that today what the mayor
of Oakland did the other day was a
disgrace where they had close to a
thousand people ready to be gotten ready
to be taken off the streets many of them
they say eighty-five percent of them
were criminals and had criminal records
and the mayor of Oakland went out and
she she went out and warned them all
scatter so instead of taking in a
thousand they took in a fraction of that
she said get out of here and she's
telling that to criminals and it's
certainly something that we're looking
at with respect to her individually what
she did is incredible and very dangerous
from the standpoint of ice and Border
Patrol very dangerous she really made
law enforcement much more dangerous now
for her part
mayor chef is deflecting that criticism
and she's going straight to the r-word
the Attorney General is trying to
distract the American people from a
failed immigration system by painting a
racist broad brush of our immigrant
community as dangerous criminals now
who's mentioning skin color or ethnicity
or where people are from that's just
pathetic
now California the way you see this
playing out is
almost acting like it's a separate
country all together not a separate
state well I think Attorney General Jeff
Sessions was 100% correct yesterday when
he labeled state officials radical
extremists for perpetuating the
lawlessness federal law determines
immigration policy state of California
is not entitled to block that activity
somebody needs to stand up and say no
you've gone too far you cannot do this
but California AG Xavier Becerra he shot
back and he argued that the state
sanctuary laws are constitutional adding
our folks are very busy doing Public
Safety around the state we don't have to
do the immigration work for immigration
officials oh excuse me
Public Safety well that's what we're
supposed to believe when your own
Oakland mayor warned the illegal aliens
ahead of time when she got wind of the
rate ice raid that was about to happen
today the White House released a partial
list of the crimes committed by the
illegal immigrants that California had
set free despite the law for requests of
immigration authorities now check it out
there's a Guatemalan citizen who was
arrested last August for injuring his
spouse well the Sonoma County Jail
provided ice with a whopping 24 minutes
notice before it released the alien a
few weeks later the Santa Rosa Police
Department in California
arrested that same individual as a
suspect in the murder of his girlfriend
another guatemalan an alleged gang
member was arrested by the san francisco
police more than 10 times between 2013
and 2017 for charges including rape
domestic battery second-degree robbery
assault vehicle theft and on each
occasion what happened was ice requested
notification of his release so then ice
could take him into custody
each time ices request was declined by
California and then a citizen of Mexico
was arrested by Santa Clara County for
drug possession On January 11 2017
he was later convicted of child cruelty
felony possession or purchase of
controlled substances
and of course possession of marijuana he
was released from local custody the list
goes on and on and we could literally do
an entire show just on the myriad ways
that California sanctuary policies have
endangered the lives of innocent
law-abiding citizens and of course law
enforcement and of course legal
immigrants California AG Basara and
governor Moonbeam Brown are living in an
alternative universe now they deny that
they even have sanctuary laws in place
yet here's what their new statutes
stipulate in violation of federal
statutes local officials cannot tell the
feds when illegals in custody are about
to be released and they're banned under
this law from transferring criminal
immigrants to federal officials now
we're talking about undocumented
criminals here and the state of
California is also so concerned about
the welfare of the illegal immigrants
that they imposed a state-run inspection
of immigrants detained by the federal
government so basically they're trying
to regulate federal immigration
detention and perhaps most outrageously
one California law now requires private
business owners to they can't
voluntarily cooperate with ice agents
now in fact they have to notify illegal
employees before any workplace
inspections take place or those private
business owners face heavy fines now you
cannot get more radical and rapidly open
borders than that though California
officials are triggered over the
sessions lawsuit it may be maybe the
beginning of restoring some sanity to
the state Republicans let's face it have
largely been shut out of California
politics now for years and we are a very
long way from the days when Pete Wilson
was governor back in the 90s permissive
liberal social welfare policies and the
embrace of illegal immigrants have
plunged the state into a spiral of
homelessness it's now at a crisis point
declared by San Francisco and Los
Angeles and even Orange County we
reported on
before is grappling with homeless
encampments and the crime and the health
issues that come along with them this is
not what the people of California want
how do I know that well a UC Berkeley
poll just found that 74% of Californians
wanted to end sanctuary cities including
65% of hispanics and 73% of democrats
now if that's not a cry for sanity or a
cry for help
I do not know what is sessions and the
Trump administration are throwing the
golden state a lifeline with these
sanctuary lawsuits because if they're
successful
perhaps the Good Vibrations political
and otherwise can roll through
California once again
and that's the angle